اعلنتا شرطه الاوكرانيه مقتل 18 شخصا
بينهم وزير الداخليه الاوكراني ونائبه
الاول وسكرتير الدوله في وزاره الشؤون
الداخليه جراء تحطم مروحيه قرب روضه
الاطفال في منطقه بكير فيما اوضح الناطق
باسم القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه ان
المروحيه تتحطمت فوق مدينه بروفاري التي
تقع على بعد 20 كيلومترا شمال شرق العاصمه
كيف ويقطنها نحو 100000 سنه
من كيف ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه حذيفه
عادل حذيفه مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض يعني كنت منذ
ساعات في هذه المنطقه التي تحطمت فيها هذه
المروحيه هل تكشفت اي اسباب او اي معلومات
جديده حتى هذه اللحظه عن سبب هذه الحادث
مساء الخير في الحقيقه بخصوص السبب تحديدا
سالت بشكل مباشر على الكسيكو وليفا قائد
الاداره العسكريه لكيف وقال ان لا يمكن في
هذه في هذا التوقيت يعني الحديث عن اي
تكهنات مازال الخبراء يعملون ما زالت
الادله الجنائيه تجمع الادله في الموقع
حتى يعني غادرت قبل دقائق فقط وما زالوا
يعملون في الموقع ويجمعون الادله حتى الان
لا يوجد سبب واضح لهذه الحادثه حتى يعني
جهاز الامن والمخابرات الاوكراني اعلن عن
فتح التحقيق ايضا في هذه الحادثه قال ان
لديه ثلاثه همم امور يبحث فيها اولا ان
يكون هذا الامر بفعل فاعل طبعا
نتيجه همم حدث هذا الحادث وايضا طبعا
هنالك مساله البروتوكول التي تمنع وجود
وزير كوزير الداخليه ونائبه وزير الدوله
في ذات الوزاره وطبعا وزير الداخليه هو
مسؤول عن الشرطه هو مسئوله عن الامن
الداخلي ومسؤول عن عده اجهزه امنيه اا
تتبع لوزاره الداخليه ونائب كذلك لذلك همم
يعني البروتوكول يمنع ان يكون في مروحيه
واحده في ظروف الحرب في مثل هذا التوقيت
لذلك يبدو ان هنالك خرق للبروتوكول جاري
الان تحقيق في هذا الامر كذلك طبعا اليوم
اعلن مجلس الوزراء عن الكشف عن اسم الوزير
بالانابه الذي سيتولى المنصب اليوم خلال
هذا اليوم سيتم اتخاذ القرار حتى الان لا
يوجد اسم معين ولكنه سوف يعلنون عن الوزير
عن الوزير المكلف خلال هذا النهار طبعا
قتل حتى الان 16 طبعا كان قد نشر ولي بان
القتلى 18 قتيلا ولكنهم عادوا الان وحدثوا
هذه المعلومه وقالوا ان القتل 16 قتيلا
بينهم ثلاثه اطفال هنالك 30 جريحنا الان
همم يتلقون الرعايه يعني شاهدنا وضع هناك
وبقايا المروحيه التي ضربت في داخل هذا
الرياض وكذلك جزء منها سقط في الجزء
الخلفي بالقرب من احد المباني يعني هنالك
ضرر كبير في رياض الاطفال كذلك همم يعني
شاهدنا همم يعني اسره لاحد الاطفال في
الموقع ويتلقون الدعم النفسي من قبل
الاختصاصيه النفسيه لانهم كانوا في حاله
نفسيه صعبه جدا في الموقع حذيفه يعني انت
موجود في اوكرانيا منذ سنوات وربما همم
يعني تعلم جيددا همم طبيعه الجغرافيه
للعاصمه كيف
وضواحيها المناطق المحيطه همم فيها
وتحدثنا عن بوفاريك تحديدا هل هذه المنطقه
الجغرافيه هي منطقه صعبه او منطقه حدثت
فيها حوادث طيران وسقوط مروحيات همم سابقا
بسبب جغرافيه المكان او حتى ظروف المناخيه
للمكان لانه يعني ربما هذا قد يساعد حتى
في همم مساله همم التحقيقات لان هذه
المنطقه ربما صعبه تقع فيها حوادث وما الى
ذلك
نعم في الحقيقه برافاري هي في ولايه كيف
وهي منطقه يعني هذه المدينه هي هي مدينه
لكنها مدينه صغيره جدا ولكنها المدينه هي
تعتبر امتداد لكييف العاصمه نفسها يعني لا
يوجد اي فرق بين تضاريس كيف المنطقه التي
انا الان فيها وبين برافاري لا يوجد فرق
في الجو في الاحوال الجويه همم حتى يعني
منذ الامس تغيرت الاحوال الجويه في كيف
الوضع همم يعني اختلف تماما كان هنالك
ثلوج الثلوج توقفت تماما وحتى على الارض
ذابت الجو صافي جدا لا يوجد ضباب لا يوجد
همم يعني كثير من الغيوم نعمل الغيوم
موجوده ولكنها في يعني في ارتفاع عالي جدا
حتى المروحيات لا تطير وتصل الى هذا
الارتفاع الجو صافي جدا همم يعني كنت قد
رسبت يعني اراء بعض الخبراء في مواقع في
القنوات الاوكرانيه في همم قنوات التلجرام
الاوكرانيه التي تحدثت عن انه قد يكون
مستبعدا قد يكون مستعدا طبعا ساتحدث كخبير
ولكن فقط يعني همم يعني همم انقل ما اراه
امامي وكذلك ما قراته همم حول هذا الامر
طبعا يستبعدون ان يتكون الاحوال الجويه هي
سبب في هذا الامر لان الجو صافي جدا اليوم
حتى درجه الحراره ارتفعت الى سبعه او
ثمانيه درجات فقط 0
شكر حذيفه عهد المراسل العربيه من كيف على
كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل